here's discovery channel's hit robot
combat show battlebots has returned and
the action is being filmed right here in
las vegas the show airs in december
featuring more than 65 teams from around
the world and rocky stopped by a taping
today to give us a behind the scenes
look
welcome to the battlebots world
championship 2021 when i walked in here
they told me don't touch anything no
watch your steps yes there's spikes
coming out the floor there are chainsaws
and there's chris our play-by-play guy
you've been here for six seasons where
are we right now yeah we are inside the
battle box so this is really the star of
the show we've got the screws behind us
we have 100 pound hammers that are
called the pulverizers we got kill saws
that jump out of the floor uh it's a
place that you might want to rent but
not buy yeah exactly and not get locked
into
not at all no no no no that's why we
left the 250 pound machines which are
really the stars of the show absolutely
step foot in here okay so what can
people expect when they watch the show
on the discovery channel it's crazy uh
everybody loves to see things blown up
and uh you know i'm no different here so
we're talking about some of the smartest
engineers and some people who are just
regular folks like you and me yeah they
build robots they spend months designing
and engineering these things and then
they can literally blow up in 30 seconds
we have fireballs we have robots that
get shot 20 feet in the air by other
machines and you have to keep in mind
these are 250 pound pieces of metal yeah
these aren't things that weigh like 10
pounds that are getting shot through the
sky that is crazy and of course when
they get shot towards the walls here
they're not going anywhere because this
is bulletproof glass it is and i was
told at the very beginning when we
started this in 2015 somebody could
stand on the other side of this thing
with a machine gun and shoot at me and
i'd be okay and i said i'm gonna let my
stunt double take care of that thank you
exactly all right now let's talk about
the audience what's the experience like
for them it's great because they watch
it on tv and then what happens is they
come here and it's an even greater
experience so if you're in las vegas
it's battlebots.com
tickets we're going to be here through
saturday i highly suggest you bring the
entire family it's fun for all as i like
to say yeah okay so you're the platelet
hey guy you've been here forever what is
the catchphrase what do we need to say i
start each and every match with
let the bot battle begin and so that'll
do it for us right now back to you in
the newsroom here on eight news now yeah
[Applause]
that was good i hear that uh tombstone
is the robot to watch i want to take my
roomba out there and see how it goes
against these guys wouldn't that be
great i think that big spinny thing yeah
you everybody has your name right ronnie
yeah his name is bronco the roomba i
think he'd do very well you got a chance
let's